[Music]
an orchestra rehearsal in love you
Ukraine they're polishing a piece by the
younger son of Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart
Franz Sava who lived and worked in
Louvre you for 30 years about two
centuries ago ukrainian conductor oksana
leav rediscovered this nearly forgotten
mozart and she initiated the review
Mozart classical music festival
dedicated to her favorite composers the
elder and younger Mozart's in the early
19th century the view lay in the
northeast corner of the austro-hungarian
Empire under Habsburg rule today it's
Ukraine's seventh largest city a vibrant
community with a well-preserved old town
it's a favorite destination for tourists
from around the world
2:33 the third day of rehearsal
[Music]
beethoven's triple concerto played by
three soloists along with musicians from
two youth orchestras Germany's
Bundesliga and orchestra and the
Academic Youth Symphony Orchestra based
in Louvre use
it's a youthful orchestra in both senses
of the term it was founded only recently
in 2016 by oxana Nene's after a German
model I worked with the Bavarian Landis
Jurgen orchestra for the first time in
Germany in 2006 I was deeply impressed
by how this is organized in Germany and
the way young people cultivate this fine
musical culture I was fascinated by the
atmosphere and the accomplishment and
the results but since then it's been my
dream to bring this experience to
Ukraine thus my Lindo green also a level
the young musicians only have four days
to rehearse they have to have the
program ready to go for the festival's
closing concert personally I could do
with some more rehearsal days it's an
unbelievably large program for such a
short time and we don't have it down
that well yet it's a wonderful young
team and you can sense the youthful
energy that's important to me and worth
a lot the professionals and the young
musicians worked and played well
together from the very first day oksana
lineThe has big plans for the German
Ukrainian Orchestra sure we're excited
we haven't had nearly enough rehearsal
time but I think it'll work out fine
we've grown together quickly it works
wonderfully the German orchestra has
fantastic musicians and we quickly found
a common language the German musicians
helped us a lot and that's important
Oxana Lena is full of energy she's very
active and productive it's colossal how
much she's accomplished in such a short
time we'll be performing with the German
orchestra for the first time the day
after tomorrow that'll be our debut and
the beginning of a journey for us would
you says
[Music]
and outing to the Carpathian Mountains
was planned but the German musicians
have barely had time to see the town the
rehearsals have top priority a lot
smoother than I thought it would
instructions are given in a cranium and
German and English but everybody still
finds where they have to come in and if
someone doesn't understand a neighbor
will help them out the rehearsal was
intense but lots of foam yeah she knows
what she wants and she has clear ideas
it's great with the others too
we've just met but it's working up very
well some of the Ukrainians don't speak
English very well but then others speak
German as Lima did not get any soy
Victor's in contact with the people I've
had contact with so far it's worked fine
we communicate one way or the other and
they're very open and obliging it's fun
to talk with them
[Music]
bulk dance again has been based in
review for over 20 years
he's a versatile composer and one of the
foremost representatives of contemporary
Ukrainian music
he's written chamber music and pieces
for Orchestra and chorus one of his
primary sources of inspiration is the
view itself the city has a rich musical
heritage which is carried on by street
musicians from all over the world
there's a creative atmosphere in the
view it has many different musical
influences and traditions lots of great
musicians and a rich musical history
[Music]
for his commission from DW bogdan Seguin
has composed an ode to his city at this
point he's still keeping it under wraps
ahead of its premiere at the Beethoven
Festival in Bonn which will be performed
by the two youth orchestras the me
pointed my leave my composition embodies
my view of the view it's a portrait of a
very multifaceted city and I made use of
something very characteristic underneath
the street musicians a hundred years ago
for instance when the view was part of
Poland but here music was very popular
that inspired me just like Beethoven's
vocal works I'm particularly fond of
some of his songs for voice and piano in
Beethoven's day they were as popular as
radio hits today
the review Mozart festival is not
limited to classical music a concert is
held on the city's historical Market
Square it's a musical encounter of two
worlds even with all the pressure ahead
of the closing concerts Oksana Lee Neff
won't miss it
[Music]
the conductor's just had four days of
intense rehearsals but it hardly shows
she lives for her work she's brought the
two youth orchestras together for a
demanding program the festival closes
with a rousing concert in the la vue
Opera House one of Europe's most
beautiful opera houses
[Music]
we're outand inside him oh man it was
thrilling at moments like these you're
rewarded for all your work and lots more
that's the thing the more you give the
more comes back
that's how so much energy came out we
were all super charged up even before
the concert it felt like the very air
was electrified the concerts a huge
success
tomorrow the orchestra will perform in
the capital Kiev before leaving for bond
to debut bulk down Seguin's composition
the mir the Kista rock
yes I'm anxious about the premiere and
bond I feel like an actor with stage
fright yet again
[Music]
three weeks later in the former capital
of West Germany bond has been hosting
the Beethoven Festival since 1845 to
honor its greatest son the event stages
four weeks of non-stop music Bogdan
Seguin and Oksana Lee Nev have been
rehearsing the new piece for four days
with the two youth orchestras and seven
young accordion players we used to be
able to perpetuate apetito Kevin Lewis
of Bemidji I was really nervous but only
in the first rehearsal after that I knew
it would work out I realized that oksana
had everything under control
it was working great and the musicians
have been steadily improving I'm very
satisfied with the result
the conductor also appears satisfied and
she's already making plans for the
future I'd like to conduct the Pearson
VUE sometime too we ought to write a
second part for it maybe a tango then
we'd have a little 20 minute cycle the
moment for the premiere has come the
accordion players take on the role of
street musicians until gradually their
notes merge with those of the orchestra
[Music]
[Music]
it's a very special evening for me my
premiere and also for Ukraine Ukrainian
Ukrainian music and culturally I am very
happy
[Music]
[Applause]